so I'm Peter Marie rust thank you very
much for inviting me I'm um I'm going to
upset a number of people I'm sorry but
it's an upsetting situation I'm going to
excite some others if ten percent of you
are with me at the end I shall feel very
happy okay and I spend much of my time
with the open knowledge foundation if
you haven't come across it the open
knowledge foundation is empowering
through open knowledge a global movement
to open up knowledge and see it used and
useful nothing to do with impact factors
nothing to do with business models but
actually to make knowledge work for
Humanity so that's going to be my theme
and and I'm afraid I have to start off
by saying that I've had very bad
experiences with elsevier I've publicly
said that I won't work with them I first
of all declined this invitation I have
nothing against David and Anita and
verse other people but I think elsevier
as a company and other commercial
publishers are doing untold harm to the
scholarship of the world at the moment
and causing great damage in many places
as an example I've spent five years
developing text mining tools we lead our
group leads the world in chemistry I've
spent half that time trying to negotiate
with elsevier to deploy it on one paper
in elsevier and I've received fob off
after platitude after whatever the last
one I got is yesterday where I asked for
elsevier to deposit supplemental
crystallographic information i will show
you that and i got a reply which I can
only describe as completely dismissive
so that doesn't square with what David
said and if we can see some way that
elsevier is actually changing heart then
I would be pleased but at the moment I
haven't seen anything my talk is as an
HTML slide it's on the web you can find
it Marie rust blog and follow it if you
want but don't all login and at one so
if you can't read it it's all up there
and so on Nellie cruise the vice
president of the european commission
said she's passionate about making
europe open she said I'm 71 I don't have
to do it I do it because I want to and
I'm spired by the new generation I'm 71
and I am inspired by the new generation
and have the great privilege with
working with some very exciting young
people and i would say next time you run
this meeting i want to see people here
who are under 35 because that is what is
going to make it happen right so I
concentrate on the long tail of
scholarship I'm going to give examples
from science but this does not just
relate to science and there are many
areas well what I say doesn't apply
basically the key thing is values we
have got our values wrong if we get our
values right then the technology and the
protocols follow the communities that I
know and respect and I'm going to talk
about global knowledge communities do it
because they are a community not because
they are using particular and technology
and so on and give a few examples of
communities that work some of them are
mainstream science and some of them I
have actually built the tools and the
repositories with my bare hands and with
those of my colleagues and some of them
are examples from outside so here's a
typical hackathon last weekend across
the world was open day today how many
people took part in open day to day
excellent right open day to day was
cities across the world working with the
citizenry not the academics of citizen
what was no suitable is how few
academics were involved and they were
building data for their cities for
journalism for all sorts of things like
that the Open Knowledge Foundation has
created a data journalism handbook which
is widely used in in journalism and you
can see there the New York Times the BBC
and so on so my simple message is that
we should create a global knowledge
Commons
now a Commons is something that works
without walls that's Cambridge that's a
cow I have eaten one of those cows or
bits of it it has the right to graze
there because it's a commons and Commons
are what we should work for and about
300 years ago in in Britain and
particularly in Scotland and England the
comments were enclosed by profit-seeking
and essentially robber barons and the
great tragedy was the destruction of
society by the enclosure of the Commons
we are fighting back this is a
University of Stanford with the mayor of
Palo Alto who ran a citywide hackathon
they close the streets off and invited
all the citizens of Palo Alto to come
and hack for 24 hours to build an
application for the city's geographical
application and that is the sort of
thing we should be doing it's exciting
it's a 21st century this is our group
here journalists stopped as this as last
Sunday and people in finance and so on
almost everybody except academics now
i'm sure you all know who this is i hope
you do that's Aaron's farts and Aaron
Swartz typifies our problem of broken
values at the moment there is a clash of
cultures here and it has resulted in
tragedy and it has to be fixed Aaron
wrote a gorilla manifesto I hope you
find time to read it I'm not going to go
through all of this here but here's Tim
berners-lee we have lost a wise elf and
the budget Aaron did is when he was 14
he built RSS when he was 14 and access
to public knowledge is a fundamental
human right now interestingly the
scourge of RW and say darrell Issa also
said that at the bottom I don't quite
know and why he says ultimately
knowledge belongs to the people of the
world and if we start on that premise
then we will make some progress so a
mindset another example came out a day
or two ago the access to the lack of
access to scholarly information means
people die now I've said this before and
I'd make no bones for saying it it is an
it is a fact and if you read this story
of Jack and Draka who when he was 14
tried to invent a cure for pancreas of
pancreatic cancer and he was stopped by
the paywalls now there is something
wrong with a culture that stops a
fourteen-year-old researching into the
disease of his best friend so we are in
the middle of digital revolution and we
are seeing a split between the cultures
and the young people are not accepting
what we have offered them and now
changing the world and if you're not
part of that you will be left behind so
where do we look for some values well
I've been very inspired by Ranganath and
the Great and Indian librarian how many
people know his laws good well books are
for use every reader his book every book
its readers save the time of the reader
the library is a growing organism you
can read all this by the way on my blog
and I've put this as data belongs to the
world I'm quite sure he would have said
that he was clear that the knowledge was
for Humanity not for the university's
data is for use every reader their data
in other words somebody wants data it's
out there the job is to get it to them
every data needs the people who can use
it save the time of the reader and the
data community is a growing organism and
that is true and it's happening outside
the walls of academia problems problems
are vested interests and academic apathy
the vested interests are terrible these
are the commercial organizations it's
primarily the publishers but it's also
instrument manufacturers and software
manufacturers and
Tiras manufacturers I've listed all of
those and they destroy the innovation
and interoperability they have destroyed
the commons and only with the commons
will we find the way to create those
tools stand up the creators of this
video wave your hands they said they
were coming right fantastic brilliant
video right about how data gets lost
most of that is due to not having the
right social structure for data if you
build the right structure it works right
the problem is we are building walled
gardens and this area is stuffed with
walled gardens reacts this is a walled
garden facebook is a walled garden I
suspect mendeley will now be a walled
garden the challenge is where the fig
share can remain not a walled garden and
to do that it must have public
governance that is believable outside of
macmillan if organisations can have
public governance of their services if
this open data up he has public
governance we have a chance if it is
just assertions by commercial
organisations then it will always go the
way of these others I've made a video
here and if you're bored with the rest
of talk you can look at it it it will
break your heart it's very tragic right
so solutions and communities at work
wikipedia the best knowledge tool in the
21st century without question how much
did it cost academia nothing when it
came out academia scoffed at it I got up
and said I believe in Wikipedia the bits
i wrote are right and that was quoted in
The Guardian but academia should have
said this is a wonderful new development
not there is a load of crap in Wikipedia
and they were wrong openstreetmap how
many people have built something with a
openstreetmap or in it right okay oh
here's this is where we are at Mont
faculty house this it was done by one
guy Steve coats in London
zero cash in the project so cash is not
the problem it is the will he said I
want to build a map of the world and he
went out and he just got people enthused
and that's what I want to do here I want
to capitalize that in the same way to
build a global research Colin Commons
for those things that work right
openstreetmap they don't worry about
their impact factor they're actually
using openstreetmap to help the lives of
people in the tropics that's what we
should be thinking about not everything
but unless we actually think what good
is this doing humanity I mean our planet
is in danger and we are unable to
release the data which will help us
solve those problems of the planet and
humanity I've just been in Melbourne
film for months we're building a bicycle
map of Melbourne this is the sort of
thing that is happening outside of
academia this is linked open data with
dbpedia at the center which is built
from those resources which people care
about these are the resources we should
build and put into Wikipedia and it
should of course all be open right
bitbucket a tool I use every day I put
my software in a repository not because
I'm mandated to but because it gives me
something I want a repository should
provide services for people it's like a
bee and a flower each benefits the other
and and that is how these things have
been created all my code is there it's
all preserved I can get anything I can
share it with people and it's got tools
far in advance of any academic
repository I've come up with principles
of a managing research data I don't have
time we must build not rent or buy tools
we can make them what I'm going to show
you here was built by graduate student
in one year and this is the best
scientific repository for physical
science that I know about I'm going to
search for silver silver bonds
which are short and I'm going to view it
here this will take a minute to load all
of this will built by a graduate student
all of it is open source and this is our
repository of material structure it
depends on the weather of bandwidth here
and it links back to the article right
what's that article so let's read the
article I'm sorry this depends on the
web a bit I knew it would do this sort
of thing all right so here it is and you
can twiddle it I mean it is a completely
interactive tool crystallography is far
in advance of other people in this
they've built their own repository I
their own ontology I'm proud to have
been part of it they have a wonderful
journal acta crystallographica e which
is a leading example of a data journal
and Thompson writers have done them the
privilege of taking it off the index
because they say it's not a proper
journal that is where we are in hock to
the arbitrary decisions of the
commercial sector okay so all of this is
open source it's all built through
something I created called the blue
obelisk with three or four other friends
and we built an open source community
for chemistry and it costs me twenty
dollars a year there is a total cost of
this open source community because I
give out blue obelisks as prizes so
we're going to do the same thing in
software we in other subjects we've
appointed in the okay to open to open
data fellows panton fellows rosemonts
and Sophie Kershaw and they are doing
their PhDs and they're also doing a
fantastic job in fighting for open data
Ross went off to Brussels last month and
fought the giants of the scholarly
publishing industry on the question of
wanting to license and restrict text
mining so we have to use whatever we can
do and as I say these young people will
do will do that we are building a
so that's Sophie running a course for
young people are so much to say here the
thing is to train young people when they
come right into the institution and
don't train it with lecturers train it
with graduate students sophie is running
that course in Oxford the final thing I
want to say is that I'm building text
mining tools with Ross so here's Ross
I've given them an Emmy Award and this
is a meet the kangaroo amy is the
equivalent of the linux penguin and amy
is going to liberate the content from
all of the scientific literature we have
weakened us on the scale we did 500,000
patents in four days on the desktop so
it's not that the only thing is the
publishers lawyers that is the major
problem and it converts these first of
all to SVG then it converts them to xml
and then it adds semantics and in
October 2013 in the UK the hargreaves
Commission was accepted it is then going
to be legal to text mine content mine
scientific papers and publish the
results non-commercial and that is the
law now I expect opposition from the
companies I'd love to hear somebody from
elsevier say yes we're delighted for you
to go ahead and I'd like them to have
the authority to make that stick so
final thing that's so what we're doing
here is a phylogenetic tree there are
10,000 of those published each year each
costs several thousand CPU hours and so
it's probably of the order of hundreds
of millions of dollars spent on it and
that is all the data you get just a
picture on a bit of paper no data no
nothing so what Amy does is actually to
'extract that into structured XML it's
been a lot of work and it's not finished
yet if you want to join that's fine but
we can read the literature into
semantics form if the publishers don't
stop us but the publishers have been
dragging their feet every time we
contact them the culture has
change so finally I have been I spent
half my time fighting we're fighting in
Europe because the publishers trying to
take tie-down text mining so the final
thing is what should we do well we're
building an open research data handbook
and we would love people to be involved
in just like we built the open
journalism handbook and we want to run
hackathon so this is my final slide here
run hackathons in things that matter to
real people based on science based on
scholarship biodiversity that is a you
know we can do that we've got all of the
tools economics of cities transport and
we're just starting material science
we've launched a semantic web for
material science last month so we have
to work for the benefit of humanity
please come and collaborate with us and
join us it'll be us